strike first strike hard no mercy ladies
and gentlemen cobra kai has returned
john and greg back at it and we got our
buddy andrew gordon from the movie
source channel to join us i look for the
people who are the biggest fans of
things and he is easily the biggest
karate kid saga fan i know he absorbs
the easter eggs andrew you're the new
koi
foreign coy today guys we go ahead hit
that like button that'd be very much
appreciated subscribe and click that
notification bell get notified when a
reaction for the next cobra kai is up
full length watch along where you sync
up with the time code or over at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
shows over there where the same tier you
get the option for reaction highlights
and watch alongs included lastly thanks
to the boys at prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights andrew
he smiles more than he's letting on
right now when i watch this episode i
will be
good good good he maintained the
stoicness all right he's a real terry
silver here
cobra car
yeah
that's what i want yeah i hope he's just
as
over the top as they would say in
cricket part three party time
okay
[Music]
he's developed class oh we always had
class
chris it's a phone call from the last
episode hello hey
a long time
[Music]
luke just throws that lightsaber
[Laughter]
[Music]
i want to see the version where he tries
to teach daniel piano yeah
begin a new era
many of us used to be enemies but
rivalries
don't need to last forever good
uplifting speech
we know that cobra kai is gonna use
every dirty trick in the book
there's only one way we're gonna be able
to be by kicking their ass is so hard
they [ __ ] themselves
[Laughter]
we're gonna teach an aggression stronger
than anything cobra kai can throw at us
they strike first
we'll pre-strike
okay let's just warm up with some simple
exercises all right light up
this is gonna go great
i like how daniel still has that cut
from season three
fighting positions
right leg back
front kick
in the kidneys
[Music]
you're just swinging at each other
don't you teach any defense best defense
is more offense
why do you have a rock in the middle of
your dojo
[Laughter]
well we're gonna get sued here uh sue me
for what we got literal dumpster fires
going right now
oh wow they work so well together yeah
i hope you die this season die a brutal
teenage death
well look who showed up
with a van sponsorship those two love
birds
i know cobra guy helped when i was
getting jumped in juvie
but i am not gonna be a pawn in this bet
that you made with my dad and mr larusso
okay
i think of you as a king oh okay damn i
would have accepted knight
i gave him every opportunity to come
back but he chose diaz
oh
that's the soft spot right there yeah
well
they have a pretty good chance of
winning now that they've teamed up
they're not the only ones teaming up
i love the continuity of seeing all the
cuts and bruises from the finale of
season three it's a good script
supervision you're doing good andrew
doing good
every scar an easter egg
kobukai shits ought to be locked up
especially that tory psycho anyone
deserves no mercy
it's her
they're gonna fight i know things are
less than ideal
a small boy was thrown through our
window oh that's right
[Laughter]
all right tonight's main course is
fajitas and grilled vegetables i have
pico de gallo and corn and flour
tortillas el gringo
i mean i'm not the only one who's
getting back together with an accent
he had a date with the love of his life
miguel
bro code dude
we took all those cool pictures and made
you look i mean not to say that you
didn't look cool already but you know
made it look special for the special
lady why don't you tell him about the
sushi we don't have to talk to him stop
no i don't know why he's being shy right
now the very good reason
that's what we thought so we got the
dragon roll jesus christ miguel
your back's gonna get broken again
i
think it's better that we don't rush
into anything with everything that
happens and everything that's still
happening
i think we should give it some time
miguel's the new villain thanks miguel
oh carla
i may help
oh my god
yes upgraded the uh hotness of his maids
since the third movie
eagle fang train's out front and i'll be
back here with the miyagi does but i
thought we were stronger working
together
we're still working together just
separately
opposite ends of the dojo
this is a terrible plan miyagi dough
should go with cobra kai
oh absolutely i supposed to have someone
spot you you know
they don't need to spot her so bad ass
ever since he cut his hair
you're right to skip practice
if you're gonna stay on defense this
isn't the right dojo for you
damn but he's bench pressing like a
hundred pounds
terence and i have a history of teaching
children with martial arts
that's adorable i had no idea you had a
karate phase karate is not a phase
it's a way of life oh crap terry's gonna
kick everyone's ass everywhere
now everyone close your eyes
and relax
stop whining like a little [ __ ] get up
rip it down please i'm trying to teach
in there keep it down
what do you want me to whisper karate's
a loud sport i can't train my students
if you're shouting obscenity obscenities
yeah kind of [ __ ] is that
[Laughter]
oh be careful with that
why do you think i'm gonna break it you
already broke a door and you stole mr
miyagi's medal and you beat the [ __ ] out
of me i'm really sorry about all that go
back with your little eagle game
you're not wanting it what the hell guys
he's not wanted eagle gang either yes
sorry so can we talk what
i don't know where to fit in here well
what did you expect you've burned
bridges with pretty much everyone here
dude don't disrespect my dojo in front
of your studio tell me how to run my
class i'll run my class over i'll do
whatever the hell i want i know what
you're doing yeah okay and as long as
you're under my roof they're both our
students oh yeah
on what roof we're outside
well played caruso and i have in common
is hating crease
i thought that was enough but it's not
can't come from a place of hate forget
it kid take down cobra kai on her own
what about rocky iii
rocky is a great movie why why did rocky
defeat clubber lane
you do it alone no i hit a bunch
again again
i'm not getting killed he's getting mad
even though they're complete opposites
they made it work and it was only
because someone had to reach out first
yeah that was apollo
[Music]
why can't larousso be apollo
first is more badass
rocky threes the movie he met ali at oh
andrew with the easter eggs oh believe
me i never stopped caring about you
never stopped caring about yell either
it was more complicated there's nothing
complicated about it
it's a choice and you chose
you're right your feelings don't matter
it's logical
if you could just come back
you really help bring everybody together
it's all that i want
you're not getting what you want
why do people think she's like so
spoiled she only has a shady see that
mercedes
i'm doing just fine
are you
because the terry silver that i knew
would have roundhouse old four-eyes back
there for calling cobra kai adorable
he's grown up man
your champ
and larusso working together that's why
i'm here
i need a partner
and the only other person who knows how
to teach cobra kai
is you
you ready to step back into the ponytail
no
back in the 80s
i thought i could conquer the world
pretty damn close i was so hopped up on
cocaine
yes yes
glad they acknowledged it
yep terrorizing a teenager over a high
school karate tournament sociopath dude
it was a great time
no alcohol required
got my ass into therapy
found
clarity
therapy just hurts people turns out you
disappearing
was the best thing that ever happened to
me
oh
please thank cheyenne for the trophy
i like the reversal how shy richard
terry for his revenge plan that's
interesting i'm sorry for
interrupting your class today
no don't apologize to show his weakness
not johnny's thinking to you
i know we got off on the wrong foot and
i'm sorry i snapped you oh apollo ding
ding yeah well
you should be sorry
[Laughter]
maybe we can hash things out wow
him
no no i'm
i'm good just give me a cup of that
juice
[Laughter]
that's so funny to me
join miyagido all on the same page and
why do i have to be the one to switch
why can't you join eagle fay
come on guys make something new miyagi
thing
you know what you know what forget it
forget it i don't know what i was
thinking
how is this ever gonna work yeah
mediator
couples therapy mindfulness app
you know if this is final then we're
gonna have to tell the kids
tell them tomorrow
rip the band-aid off
like badasses
my dad was gone by the time i woke up
do you know if you had a chance to
connect with johnny
no i didn't see him this morning either
what's up hawk
ha
oh
get a load of this chunk
what are you doing here
since they crease isn't back yet so i'm
going to get you guys warmed up oh [ __ ]
get the hell out of here man who says we
even want you
okay hit me if you can
all
right who's next
get him robbie
oh my he's gotta murder them
some good choreography here
damn not one person
punch her in the face see that guys you
want to win a woman's heart you beat her
up ouch
i'll do the deal
i'll go
expecting you to stay to stay
[Laughter]
okay
so that's how you win a girl's heart you
beat her up hey learn a lot from this
[ __ ] i in the sensei now the sooner we
get this over with the better whatever
let's just get on the same page at how
we're going to break it down
what the [ __ ] hawk what are you doing
back it's coming down
hey what are you doing
talk is cheap
so i'm building a bridge but more
specifically an okinawan sparring deck
what
mr miyagi just used this area for extra
storage but a new deck would mean a lot
more room for training
we're all gonna help build it
assuming our sensei's approved
oh you guys
it was them teaching us all a lot
sounds good to me
yeah
sounds awesome
thanks for not letting me go out with
your mom we all need to look ourselves
in the mirror
realize who we really are
terence
would you be darling and get a bottle of
mara shea from your cellar
of course
god i miss cocaine
and defeat the enemy it helps to know
the enemy's playbook that's why i'm
going to teach you miyagido karate
[ __ ]
they're warmed up for you i
oh man
robbie you were the chosen one
for the story of the dark side i joined
them
we both had a hard time pulling that
quote i know
it's okay
teamwork
[Music]
still get eyes
is everything okay a kicker head
coming that's a good adrenaline rush
[Music]
oh cool
great first episode
[Music]
oh i'm so glad they did that yeah
hell yeah
hey pause
it lot of you guys might not know that
as a result family friend of the album
family friend of the alba's great loss
for us
and uh yeah we'll miss him
let's stay focused on that and not
transition back to talking about the
show this is a headache
it's a great man that had money as hell
all right hey that was
that was right just
this show
is so good you know it just like
throws you right into it and you're like
just as good as you always have been
show every single time
man what a solid pilot i like how it
picks up with some version of
expectations of like you know terry
silver
throwing the lightsaber over her
shoulder and then they do it again with
uh
you know with the miyagi doe like let's
begin
they don't even know what they're doing
there's such a cool moment at the end of
last season and then they realized oh
they're they're really clueless about it
all uh this was really solid man terry
silver stuff is definitely the most
exciting part too it'd be just
especially if like i mean did you watch
crowded kid three perfect i re-watched
it last night just to prepare myself and
you've seen it like so many times it's a
great movie it's the best recording it's
a great move out there everyone says it
is oh it's so fun it's so fun it's so
damn fun and then i like taking this
there's sort of like an action hero
approach with the way they're doing
terry silver that like
aged up
former guy who used to be like so
eccentric and he's like the grounded
version of him older you know that trope
of like
you're the key we need you to come back
and save our operation no i'm retired
i'm out of the game not coming but now
he's having his reconsiderations while
making fun of people in california the
kind of folk we'd hang out with
that's for sure but andrew what'd you
think man i think you said it best
subversion of expectation was the uh
let's see that bam right away you got in
there it was so impressive perfect that
was so impressive
i mean from the moments you guys
mentioned with the lightsaber moment
obviously we had hawk with the
sledgehammer we're like oh [ __ ] is he
going to break that picture or what's he
getting at the rock or
no they're just
building a uh nice okinawan bridge or
whatever and so i mean i like that they
were going for that and i mean my
favorite part obviously of karate kid
part 3 which i'm sure many of yours is
of course terry silver so i'm so glad
that they got thomasy and griffith back
i know he's retired but that was great
oh really and brought him out of
retirement yeah well come on it's cobra
kai you got to come back uh for out of
retirement but i think about the essay
about the
that uh i most appreciated i mean
besides like just seeing all the
characters back season four again was
the chemistry between chris and terry
silver like that's the strongest point
for me when it comes to cry kid part
three for years i did not really care
for that film i know you guys just said
you love that film but after cobra kai
season 3 with the depth and the uh what
we got from the flashbacks with crease
and silver like that movie made me just
appreciate their relationship when you
re-watch karate kid part three because
again you see where where it all their
relationship started and why they care
for each other so much it's just it's
just got a nuance and such an in-depth
uh relationship so i'm just glad to see
again like the falling out and just
obviously we know that he's gonna you
know come back and help crease and all
that but again just seeing them together
was just the highlight for me and of
course we gotta really quickly mention i
love that they uh paid homage uh uh to
uh the great ed azner i thought that was
very nice i wasn't expecting that at
first just because my mind was just so
into this episode but seeing that warmed
my heart yeah go j jonah jameson i think
uh spider-man animated series yes people
can't review
what jk simmons
is going to talk about victor
uh and he's actually uncle ben in
spectacular spiderman uh so but yeah the
the whole thing with um terry silver at
the end i like when they the show takes
something that is so
like they deconstructed really really
quick with going to the montage of like
like we does the movie ever say he's
hopped up on cocaine because it's so
obvious that he is in that film like
it's such the embodiment of like 80s x
like the wolf of wall street kind of
character that 80s like narcissistic
greedy guy and i love that they broke
down just this is that's why i love the
movie i'm like it's just so insane it's
so ridiculous like you got this really
pleasant story with miyagi and and
daniel
and the girl across the street and it
just always takes such a shift to what
you got to
terry it's just so amplified and i i
love it because of that reason but i
like that they did
the grounded approach with a minute and
like the subtle character nuance
especially when he i didn't actually see
that coming where he's gonna kick the
bottle at the end against the wall i
thought that was great and then like
hawk
you know there was
got a lot of crap for saying this um in
the last season i remember this i was
like
spent like hours editing that video and
then all people fixated on was something
i said way late into the video one of
those
was i had a little bit of gripe with uh
the way hawk's turn
went
in that it wasn't a big deal to me but
it was something that i was like
everyone's gonna fixate on this so um
yeah and here they're dealing with that
now now they're really dealing with it
of like you're not really accepted
anywhere you betrayed copper cry you
attacked me akita oh you're you're not
accepted any of this and i like that
we're gonna deal with him having a path
of redemption as well upon all of this
guys clearly craig had not seen a world
wrestling entertainment match before so
that's why he's driving this moment
but no i i i take it away john
not editing this down take it away i
agree with
approach to how they continue their
events it's very linear in in the way
that they set these building blocks down
but i think they take
uh i'm just gonna use the word
conscientious again approach to
uh thinking of what the real
repercussions of these moments would be
like you're good at drawing that
dramatic yeah you have that punch at the
end of the season like oh this is gonna
be awesome they're teaming up but now
that's the beginning of a whole new
journey and they're really good at being
conscious of that and expanding the
story with that in mind and so i think
they've you know like a lot of things
happen in this episode that you kind of
expect to happen ultimately but they
feel very natural because of the
attention that they've paid to the
characters and the fact that yeah
whenever a new prospect happens or one
character comes to another and you know
says their piece and tries to entice
like they're good at having uh natural
debates around these things and then
paying them off either in a satisfying
way where you think it might pay off or
subverting your expectations well i
think what they do really well is like
even though we know some plot beats are
gonna happen like we know
that the robbie is gonna go to cobra kai
we know that daniel and johnny will [ __ ]
we'll
have at least a temporary time trying to
make it we're gonna really know but we
know that this episode will not end with
i'm just going all right we're splitting
up yeah you know like we know that but
what i think is cool is that you see the
character it's about the journey not
really about the end beats of it
because you see like um
oh my god what is her name samantha uh
trying to talk about the girl yeah
spoiler girl spoiled brat yeah it's
everything hannah everything's always
good for her all the time
no struggles for this character
but you have samantha uh like trying to
talk to robbie initially even though we
know it's not gonna go the way we expect
i like that you get a scene to really
flesh it out that's like that's what's
so great about these shows they they
flush things out of robbie talking with
crease at first and being like nah man
like
that that adds so much more impact or
even johnny and daniel probably the most
predictable part was that they were
always going to have to make it work at
the end of this episode in some way
something would have to happen but you
don't see that coming though with the
whole thing with uh hawk trying to work
to build the bridge apparently they
didn't tell anyone about it
and also you mentioned earlier i love
how they did the role reversal of uh
crease recruiting uh terry this time
around whereas in part three as we
remember crease went to give up the dojo
keys and then he sent him to tahiti and
then he wanted to do the revenge tour
basically for him so it's it's i mean
that's what i love about this show is
there's a lot of role reversals a lot of
changes from the series but still they
would still respect the original series
so and they also what's cool though too
is one thing in karate kid 3 that
um i thought they did to crease was they
diminished his villain status because it
really elevated terry
and made terry seem like the one with
the power right i agree with you but
also too um just to add to your point um
the actor martin cove he was i forgot
which film he was filming in 1988 or 89
when they were filming that so he could
barely be on set uh
so they had to diminish his role big
time but yes i agree with what you're
saying though i'm not attacking actor
martin cove
no no
i'm just saying where they had to write
the character down from he was he was
originally supposed to be in the film a
lot more than it was originally intended
so so what i love that they do here
is the way the dynamics are established
is crease is back in the power position
between this whole villain recruitment
and uh running cobra kai you know like
it still seems like terry would be
supporting to crease versus how it just
like chris took over increases top dog
and like increased his answers to terry
now you know
the way i did chronic e3 so i like that
the the the power dynamics are very much
present i mean we don't know maybe maybe
terry will try to pull the wrong head
over him and be like cover because mine
now or or maybe he'll go see johnny and
danny because he did seem to at least
acknowledge that like i i terrorized a
teenager all those years ago but i think
that's part of the power of creases he
could pull out the worst in you that's
true yeah and i can't wait to see that
moment when daniel and terry uh see each
other for the first time but i'm
probably gonna die on this and hill
alone i'm probably gonna be wrong and
you guys can call me out on it when it
is when i am wrong but you think jaden
smith is better yes uh dude do you guys
think that terry's on the show do you
think it's gonna be revealed that terry
silver is miguel's father because i when
i re-watched cobra kai season one uh and
also in season two carmen did mention to
uh johnny twice not once but twice that
miguel's father was very rich and
powerful and he was a bad man i mean
it's funny when i saw that woman show up
uh the worst day i was like that kind of
reminds me of mom a little bit i'm not
i'm probably gonna be totally wrong on
that but i don't know it's just they
mentioned it you can look it up now oh
wow if you wanted to stick to it now
let's have it spoiled for you man like
we did with no way homie yeah
i know everything all the leaks
we don't need to look this up man it's
very good no i'd rather be surprised i'd
like you to be right that that would be
a great thing to be right about yeah
that'd be impressive that would be a
nicely caught detailing cobra koi
that's a show i would watch
yeah nikoi doesn't even need to fight
anybody he just talks
she talks about the submission
all right any other easter eggs you
notice andrew you want to point out
really quick not at the moment but uh
fail yeah yeah let's talk about all
those scars from the prince that was
good that was good continuity i will i
will admit i i really did like that
something uh the mcu does a really good
job of too is just you know keeping up
the scars i think spider-man homecoming
is where we saw that where tony still
had the scars from the captain america
civil war i mentioned that to you in
theaters is this the first season to
pick up like seconds
like well yeah right at the end the
season season three started a few weeks
after season two ended and then uh when
season two and uh did not start right
after season one so i believe you're
correct this was yeah this was like
literally overlapping because like you
see the other side of the phone call at
the start of the season yeah interesting
how we plan on all the greatest things
got the spider-man no way home
transition from far from home ending the
beginning what happened to the computer
it's just been on a while and now it's
idling all right
can you
touch a button
all right all right guys well thanks so
much for being here
andrew appreciate that rocky iii
pointing thing out
one over my head dude you're welcome the
apollo creed of this review
thanks guys so you pointed it out free
struck first it's like a badass running
the video now follow andrew on movie
sources see guys
all right
that was good it's better one